[Musik]
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
In meinem heutigen Video möchte ich euch
einfach so ein bisschen einen Einblick geben in unseren Alltag,
genauer gesagt, in unseren neuen Alltag.
Momentan sind ja wirklich alle zu Hause.
Die Kinder haben schulfrei.
Die Kitas und Kindergärten haben geschlossen.
Das heißt, die meiste Zeit
sind Eltern mit ihren Familien zu Hause,
dürfen oder müssen Lehrer zu Hause spielen,
die Schulaufgaben erledigen, die Kinder beschäftigen.
Und es ist wirklich für alle eine ganz neue Situation,
vor allem weil man eben zu Hause ist
in seiner Familie, mit seiner Familie,
aber irgendwie auch fremde Menschen oder auch Freunde,
die Großeltern nicht treffen darf.
Und das ist für alle ganz neu.
Aber ich würde sagen,
das ist eine schöne neue Situation, eine Chance
und es ist einfach ein ganz neuer Tagesablauf.
Und ich zeige ich heute in diesem Video,
wie wir gerade unseren Tagesablauf meistern,
was wir machen,
was es für Tipps und Tricks gibt,
wie ihr die Kinder beschäftigen könnt
und wie ihr trotzdem als Pärchen oder auch als Einzelperson
nicht zu kurz kommt.
Bei uns ist es so, wir arbeiten ja sowieso zu Hause.
Das heißt, hier haben wir einfach
unsere Wohnung sozusagen,
auf der anderen Seite der Garage
haben wir unser Küchenstudio,
unsere Küche, in der wir unsere YouTube-Filme drehen.
Unser Drehalltag hat sich im Prinzip nicht verändert.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, wie gesagt,
dass die Kinder von morgens bis abends zu Hause sind
und eben mit uns den Alltag verbringen.
Wichtig ist da jetzt momentan nicht,
einfach die Zeit zu verbringen,
sondern die Zeit sinnvoll zu nutzen.
Das heißt, wirklich schöne Momente
mit euren Kindern erleben,
schöne Momente mit eurem Ehepartner erleben,
aber auch Zeit für sich selber zu finden.
Das Ganze kann man sich so vorstellen wie eine Art Pyramide.
Ich kann euch das hier mal aufzeichnen.
Das hier ist jetzt sozusagen die Zeitpyramide.
Also ihr habt hier
die Pyramide.
Und die ist jetzt bei uns zumindest auf drei aufgeteilt.
Denn wir sind eine Familie mit Kindern.
Hier ganz unten das ist wirklich der größte Part.
Das ist die Familienzeit.
Dicht gefolgt
und nicht zu vernachlässigen, die Paarzeit.
Und da folgt auf der Spitze des Turms
und ich weiß, es kommt bei den meisten zu kurz,
die Ichzeit.
Man sollte sich selber nämlich auch nie vergessen.
Das heißt, hier bin ich alleine,
hier mit meinem Partner
und hier
Eltern mit Kind,
Ob jetzt eins, zwei oder drei
oder noch mehr,
ist im Prinzip egal.
Und diese Zeitpyramide, die ist nicht nur jetzt wichtig,
jetzt, wo ihr alle zu Hause seid,
sondern eigentlich in eurem ganzen Alltag immer wichtig.
Ihr solltet wirklich immer genügend Familienzeit mit einplanen.
Und damit meine ich auch gezielt Familienzeit,
also schön Zeit mit euren Kindern verbringen
mit eurem Ehemann zusammen oder Ehefrau zusammen.
Paarzeit, das heißt, ohne Kinder auch mal
die Zeit zu zweit verbringen.
Und natürlich die Ichzeit:
Was macht euch persönlich Spaß?
Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht
alleine das Bad putzen, alleine kochen,
sondern wirklich alleine was für sich tun.
Was ich in der Zeit zum Beispiel gerne mache,
ist lesen oder ein bisschen Sport.
Momentan darf ich eben nicht ins Fitnessstudio,
aber dafür kann ich dann auch zu Hause
ganz isoliert was machen.
Und vor allem, wenn ich die Ichzeit habe,
kann es einfach auch sein,
dass der Murat dann gerade auf die Kinder aufpasst.
Und wenn ich dann eben keine Ichzeit habe,
sondern der Murat,
passe ich eben auf die Kinder auf.
Also das könnt ihr euch wirklich richtig schön einteilen.
[Musik]
Was momentan für uns alle das Wichtigste ist,
ist, dass der Tagesablauf strukturiert ist.
Also nicht einfach so in den Tag hinein leben.
Könnt ihr auch machen.
Aber es wird auf Dauer sehr schnell langweilig
und vor allem geht man sich dann
vielleicht irgendwann wirklich tatsächlich auf die Nerven.
Das heißt, ich plane den Alltag für uns alle.
Nicht so konsequent wie jetzt in der Schule.
In der Schule übernehmen das ja die Lehrer, die Stunden,
der Schulunterricht, der Stundenplan.
Zu Hause habe ich jetzt hier
für Samira auch einen Wochenplan.
Und das machen wir dann wirklich von Woche zu Woche.
Wir haben von der Schule
auch ganz viele Aufgaben bekommen,
die sie jetzt in der Zeit erledigen darf.
Und ich habe das Ganze hier aufgeteilt
von Montag bis Sonntag.
Samstag und Sonntag darf sie natürlich Freizeit machen,
einfach Wochenende.
Und Lesen und Kopfrechnen machen wir
sowieso eigentlich fast täglich.
Und alle anderen Aufgaben habe ich jetzt hier
schön aufgeteilt in Schulwochen.
Das solltet ihr wirklich auch machen
und mit dem Kind zusammen auch gerne durchplanen.
Denn so weiß euer Kind, was zu tun ist,
kann natürlich auch selbst direkt mitbestimmen.
Ältere Kinder können das vielleicht
sogar auch schon selber machen.
Und Samira bekommt dann hier diesen Wochenplan
und kann wirklich Aufgabe für Aufgabe abarbeiten
und einfach dann auch schön markieren
und mit einem Häkchen versehen.
Denn dann weiß sie, was sie schon erledigt hat.
Das Ganze motiviert natürlich auch ungemein.
Und Ela zum Beispiel, die ist vier Jahre alt.
Sie hat jetzt auch kindergartenfrei,
aber hat jetzt keinen Stundenplan.
Die Ela macht aber trotzdem
hier auch ganz gerne mit.
Das heißt, morgens ist für uns so die Schulzeit.
Samira erledigt die Schulaufgaben.
Ela spielt dann Schule.
Das heißt, sie malt dann ein bisschen
oder versucht, Schreibübungen zu machen,
oder
sie tut so, als würde sie gerade was lesen.
Samira macht ihre Hausaufgaben größtenteils alleine.
Aber natürlich bin ich trotzdem als Ansprechpartnerin da
oder erkläre ihr was, wenn sie was nicht versteht.
Und Ela kann auch ganz alleine lernen
und hat auch so ein bisschen
Beschäftigungszeit für sich alleine.
Sie nutzt nämlich dann auch ganz gerne
die YouTube Kids App.
Da gibt es nämlich auch ganz, ganz viele tolle Lernvideos.
Das heißt, sie kann zum Beispiel das ABC lernen
oder Zahlen lernen.
Wir schauen auch supergerne englische Lieder an
oder hören sie an.
So kann sie auch schon mal
den englischen Wortschatz ein bisschen üben.
Und über die YouTube Kids App weiß sie einfach,
was sie alles anklicken darf.
Da gibt es oben einfach dieses Feld Lernen
oder Entdecken oder auch Musikhören und Serienschauen.
Und wenn ich sage, "Ela, komm,
jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen Schulzeit,
lerne doch ein bisschen was",
kann sie einfach in der App ihre Inhalte aussuchen
oder ich suche sie ihr aus
und dann darf sie das gerne anschauen.
Und das macht sie auch wirklich total selbstständig
und verbringt so einfach ihre Zeit auch schön alleine.
[Musik]
Sieben.
Drei,
vier, fünf, sechs,
sieben, acht, neun, zehn.
[Musik]
Mama, ich bin fertig.
Komme.
Ich bin schon fertig mit dem Aufgabenblatt.
Alles erledigt?
Ja.
Perfekt.
Guck mal, dann geh du doch ein bisschen spielen.
Oder was möchtest du jetzt machen?
Basteln? Spielen? Malen?
Basteln!
Also YouTube Kids?
Ja!
[Musik]
Hallo, ihr Lieben!
Herzlich willkommen bei TobiLotta!
Hallöchen, liebe Bastelfreunde!
Ich muss euch was sagen!
Ich habe euch...
Ich habe euch
so sehr vermisst!
Ach, wie süß. Ja, auch ich habe euch alle vermisst!
Und um ganz ehrlich zu sein...
Ach, menno!
Mir ist es so was von langweilig!
Ach, Lotta. Ich weiß, dir ist es langweilig. Aber ich...
Wir nutzen übrigens gerade verschiedene Arten bei Samira
zum Lernen.
Zum einen hat sie natürlich ihren Schulstoff, den sie hat.
Es gibt aber auch viele Kinder, die in der Schule
jetzt nicht so viele Hausaufgaben bekommen haben,
Samiras Freundin zum Beispiel.
Die nutzen auch viele Onlineplattformen zum Lernen.
Zum einen gibt es da Plattformen,
wo man einfach
jetzt kostenloses Unterrichtsmaterial bekommt.
Zum anderen nutzt Samira aber auch
zum Beispiel die YouTube Kids App zum Lernen.
Da kann sie sich nämlich Mathe-Spiel-Songs anhören
oder einfach verschiedene Dinge lernen,
Geschichten anhören.
Und die nutzt sie auch ganz gerne.
Vor allem kann sie dann schauen,
was sie jetzt gerade lernen möchte,
ob es jetzt Vokabeln sind
oder Englisch-Wörter
oder Englisch-Songs
oder ob sie wirklich das Einmaleins lernen will.
Da schaut sie dann nach, kann lernen
und das Ganze ist dann eben spielerisch.
Manchmal mangelt es einfach nur an einer guten Methode.
Und genau das will ich euch heute zeigen.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie ich meinen Schülern
das Einmaleins beibringe,
was ich den Eltern erkläre
und warum das aus meiner Erfahrung
in den letzten zehn Jahren
wirklich einen großen Erfolg hat.
Also gehen wir es gemeinsam durch.
Da drinnen steckt auch gleichzeitig die Geteiltaufgabe.
Denn 6 geteilt durch 6 ist 1.
Seht ihr es?
Ein mal 6 ist 6
und 6 geteilt durch 6 ist eins.
Also nicht so stur und stupide
auf dem Platz sitzen und was auswendig lernen,
sondern wirklich spielerisch, teilweise mit Musik begleitend.
Und das macht ihr auch wirklich superviel Spaß!
Jetzt kommt für uns unsere Spielzeit.
Gerade für die Kinder ist jetzt ganz wichtig zu wissen:
Ihr habt jetzt Spielzeit.
Entweder gehen sie jetzt nach draußen
oder sie spielen in ihren Zimmern.
Und die Zeit kann man echt auch ganz gut nutzen
entweder als Familienzeit, also als gemeinsame Spielzeit,
oder man kann sie auch als Ichzeit nutzen,
also, dass die Kinder jetzt auch wirklich die Zeit haben,
mal zu tun und zu lassen, was sie wollen,
nichts vorgeschrieben bekommen.
Und auch die Ela, die vier Jahre alt ist,
oder die Samira mit ihren fast zehn Jahren
brauchen natürlich auch eine Ichzeit
und muss einfach ihre Zeit auch selber einteilen dürfen.
Das heißt, sie kann jetzt entscheiden,
ob sie spielen will, ob sie was lesen will,
ob sie basteln oder kreativ sein will
oder einfach die Musik anschmeißen und mittanzen will.
Das kann hier wirklich jeder für sich selbst entscheiden.
Murat wird jetzt gleich mit den Kids
nach draußen gehen in den Garten.
Die wollen nämlich jetzt noch was streichen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt gerade sowieso zu Hause seid,
könnt ihr die Zeit auch ganz gut nutzen,
um Dinge zu tun, für die normalerweise im Alltag,
wenn jeder zur Arbeit geht,
nicht so viel Zeit ist.
Ja. Aufräumen, ausmisten, streichen,
renovieren,
reparieren
und all die anderen schönen, tollen Dinge.
[Musik]
Können wir jetzt wieder weiter legen?
Also wir gucken im Alltag immer schon,
dass wir viele Gesellschaftsspiele spielen.
Skip-Bo spielen wir mit Samira ganz gern.
Ela lernt es auch gerade.
Und wir spielen das eigentlich schon jeden Abend.
Normalerweise auch mit Oma und Opa immer,
jetzt momentan nur zu viert.
Memory spielen wir ganz gerne.
Also es gibt wirklich ganz viele tolle Spiele,
die man zu Hause spielen kann.
Probiert es wirklich auch, jeden Tag zu spielen.
Es macht echt superviel Spaß!
Hörst du auf zu...
Hör auf zu veräppeln! Hallo!
Sie hat gesagt, ich soll es da reinstecken.
Also da könnt ihr wirklich mal in eurem Schrank schauen,
was ihr noch alles so an Spiele habt.
Hierhin!
Hallo! Hallo!
Was?
Papa!
Und wir zeigen euch gleich noch ein kreatives Spiel.
Samira, das Malspiel!
Ich habe gesagt,...
Okay, dann bin ich jetzt dran.
...er soll sie halten!
Wieso muss ich mit ihr spielen?
Die kann doch nicht mal bis zehn zählen!
Doch, kann sie!
Ela, sag es ihm!
Zeig mal, wie du zählen kannst!
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn.
Tschakka!
Okay. Noch einen Test noch, okay?
Buchstabiere mal Steueridentifikationsnummer.
Wie geht das aber?
Ach, super! Warum muss ich mit ihr spielen?
Das kann dir der Papa auch nicht erklären.
Der kann es nämlich auch nicht schreiben.
Steueridentifikationsnummer.
Sag mal.
Veräppel sie nicht!
Sie kann zumindest zu den Zahlen auch...
Was sind das für Nummern?!
Okay.
Sie kann zumindest zu den Zahlen auch tanzen, gell, Ela?
Ich kann nur die Karte spielen.
[Musik]
Was übrigens auch ein ziemlich cooles Spiel ist,
dafür braucht ihr nur einen Stift und Zettel
oder sogar ein iPad.
Unterwegs könnt ihr das nämlich auch spielen.
Machen wir auch normalerweise gerne im Auto zum Beispiel.
Also ihr nehmt einfach einen Stift
und der eine kritzelt was drauf,
was Einfaches, irgendwie so.
So. Und jetzt bekommst du das
und kannst jetzt das Blatt drehen und wenden.
Und dann schaut sie, was sie sieht,
und malt das Bild sozusagen fertig.
Also was richtig Kreatives.
Was siehst du?
Ich überlege gerade noch.
Ledidu.
Okay. Nicht zu kompliziert.
So ungefähr so.
Drei Sekunden
tschu.
Ich weiß was.
Na, wie sieht es aus?
Sage ich nicht.
Darf ich es dir zeigen?
Ich habe was.
[Musik]
Das ist auf dem iPad auch ziemlich cool,
weil dann kann man
auf ein und derselben Kritzelei mehrere Bilder machen,
also auch so wie so eine Challenge.
Gell?
Ja.
Die Kreativ-Challenge.
Und man kommt dann auch rein,
also es wird von Mal zu Mal immer kreativer und abgespacter.
Du bist wieder dran.
Ich bin wieder dran?
Okay.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wir hatten doch schon alles mögliche, nicht?
Wir gucken auch mal zusammen.
Darf ich mal kurz?
Oh. Das könnten wie so zwei Monsterwellen sein
und da drin ist ein Surfer.
Nein! Ich will.
Ich weiß was.
Oh, das ist cool, Samira!
Ui!
Guck. Das geht hier dann halt so.
Hm.
Und das hier.
Wie so ein Piranha.
Voll gut!
Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi!
Fertig!
Guck mal, Mama, wie süß!
Hast du Selfies gemacht?
Hast du mein Handy geklaut und Selfies gemacht, Ela?
Ja.
Jetzt bin ich dran.
O Gott!
Zeig mal!
Ela hat Selfies gemacht.
Okay. Man muss auch dazusagen,
dass man Selfies auch im gesperrten Zustand machen kann.
Mama!
Ich habe dir was hingekritzelt.
Was ich jetzt momentan auch sehr wichtig finde
vor allem, wenn ihr gerade viel zu Hause seid,
solltet ihr wirklich auf die Mediennutzung der Kinder achten.
Also lasst sie jetzt nicht einfach
wahllos vor dem Fernseher sitzen
und Fernsehen schauen den ganzen Tag,
sondern beschäftigt sie, lasst sie sich selbst beschäftigen.
Sie können lernen. Sie können Spaß haben.
Aber, was ich wirklich ganz doof finde, ist,
wenn man sie wirklich vor dem Fernseher parkt.
Denn im Fernsehen kann man zum einen
nicht entscheiden, was sie schauen,
wie viel sie es schauen.
Und vor allem kommen da einfach
die ganze Zeit Werbeblöcke.
Und ihr kennt es vielleicht,
also wir haben es auch schon erlebt,
dass die Kinder dann einfach die Werbung mitträllern
und einfach dann zu viel geschaut haben.
Und wenn ihr die Kinder schon an die Medien lasst,
dann wirklich gezielt.
Deswegen haben wir auch
die YouTube Kids App runtergeladen.
Da kann ich nämlich für beide Kinder einfach Profile erstellen,
Samira fast zehn Jahre alt, Ela eben vier Jahre alt.
Die beiden haben natürlich auch verschiedene Interessen.
Sie können dort lernen,
sie können Spaß haben,
sich aber auch mal Serien anschauen.
Und ich kann das Ganze auf Zeit limitieren.
Und, wenn ich möchte, kann ich sogar Profile oder Kanäle,
die ich persönlich einfach nicht so schön finde,
auch blockieren.
Das heißt, sie sehen wirklich nur das, was ich möchte,
und so lange, wie ich es eben eingestellt habe.
Und so kann man den Kindern
einen gesunden Medienumgang beibringen,
sie ein bisschen herantasten lassen.
Klar, lassen wir sie auch mal ans Handy
und lassen sie dann eben auch was anschauen
auch gerade so zum ein bisschen Runterfahren.
Sie können sich da Hörbücher anhören.
Also die haben da wirklich
eine ganz große Anzahl an Dingen, die sie tun können,
und ich habe trotzdem die Kontrolle drüber.
Und die Kinder sind eben auch mal eine Zeit lang beschäftigt,
ohne dass ich sie jetzt beschäftigen muss.
Am Abend schauen wir uns dann auch den Sandmann an,
wenn wir es im Fernsehen verpasst haben.
Und vor allem können wir uns
so dann einfach die Folge selber aussuchen.
Und ja,
Samira hat eine etwas größere Medienzeit als Ela,
weil sie eben schon älter ist.
Sie lernt ja auch damit und bastelt viel damit.
Und die Ela, die darf einfach noch nicht so viel schauen,
weil sie eben noch das kleinere
und jüngere Geschwisterkind ist.
[Musik]
Ich habe meine Community übrigens
heute Morgen auch gefragt:
Wie beschäftigt ihr denn eure Kinder?
Was macht ihr gerade zu Hause?
Jetzt schauen wir uns mal die Antworten an, okay?
Also ich bin echt gespannt.
Da haben einige sich gemeldet.
Guck mal.
Brettspiele, Puzzles, backen, basteln, Lego spielen.
Backen ist immer so ein cooles Thema,
weil da
Backen ist toll!
lernen die Kinder,
Wie soll ich es sagen?
Selbstständig zu werden.
Für die Familie zu sorgen.
Schritt für Schritt zu arbeiten.
Ja.
Man sollte nur den gesunden Ausgleich finden
zwischen backen und kochen und gesunden Rezepten.
Ansonsten werden wir alle kugelrund.
Guck mal. Da schreibt eine:
"Der arme Hund muss ständig mit uns spazieren gehen."
Malen und backen.
"Ich lasse ihnen die Langeweile."
Das ist übrigens gar nicht, gar keine
doofe Idee manchmal.
Ja.
Auch Kinder dürfen sich mal langweilen.
Das stimmt.
Das ist was ganz, ganz Normales.
Man muss nicht immer voll unterwegs sein
Hm.
und irgendwas machen.
Also lasst sie sich einfach langweilen.
Weil aus der Langeweile entsteht nachher
etwas Kreativität.
Also bei Samira zumindest.
Bei Ela entsteht immer
irgendeine Sauerei.
Ja, irgendwas.
Ja, stimmt. Die Samira wird da immer kreativ.
Ja.
Und die Ela,
da entsteht...
Wenn die mal ruhig ist...
Ihr wisst das ja, wenn ihr mal Kinder habt,
dann ist Stille nicht immer toll.
Also die letzten drei Male, als Ela
still war und lange Zeit alleine war,
waren drei Lippenstifte kaputt.
Die waren komplett überall.
Aber klar, bei deinen Zuschauern sieht man ganz oft
Backen und wir gestalten unseren Garten.
Oh, was auch cool ist,
ein Filmeabend.
Oh ja!
Es ist auch richtig cool, mal ein paar,
einfach mal sich Popcorn hinrichten
und so einen coolen Filmabend mit den Kids,
so einen Kinoabend zu machen.
Das ist auch noch richtig cool, gell?
Ja.
Und da dürfen auch mal Chips da sein.
Das stimmt.
Für Papa.
Was ihr momentan auch schön mit Kindern machen könnt,
ist
Kresse einpflanzen.
Also entweder nehmt ihr
ein bisschen Watte und Kressesamen
und könnt es einfach in kleine Schüsselchen machen.
Wir haben hier jetzt noch was richtig Cooles!
Guck mal. Was steht da drauf, Samira?
Einfach mal die Kresse halten!
Hat uns der Christian mitgebracht.
Guckt mal.
Und da sind so kleine Beutelchen drin.
Da war eben schon einer.
Jetzt können wir die Kresse schön einpflanzen
und dann wächst die.
Und jeden Tag können wir dann die Kresse beobachten.
Okay?
Mama, in jede kleine...
Ich nehme dann nur einen – Genau – Löffel.
Einfach so Erde rein. Ja.
Die kann man auch nach draußen pflanzen
oder drinnen.
Aber, wie gesagt, ohne Erde geht es auch ganz gut.
Hier, Ela.
Ich will auch mal!
Hä, warum ist da jetzt ein Beutel – Da guck – drin?
Da sind doch die Samen drin.
[Musik]
So.
Und jetzt, hier nehmt euch mal die Kresse in die Hand.
Jeder dann ein bisschen.
[Musik]
Ich darf auch!
Nein! Wir nehmen jetzt...
Nee, warte. Und jetzt gießen.
Guck, ganz wenig Wasser.
Darf ich gießen?
Ja.
Aber zusammen.
Zusammen. Okay.
Warte, warte.
Hebe es fest.
Und los.
Gießen, gießen.
Gießen, gießen, gießen.
Und dann einfach beobachten.
Und essen
auf Butterbrot, hä?
Ja.
Oder im Salat.
Oder Käsebrot.
Mmh!
Also ich meine...
Oder auf Wurstbrot.
Oder Wurstbrot. Ja.
[Musik]
Baust du es zusammen.
Und nachher muss es so aussehen.
Okay?
So.
Und das sind...
Das? Genau. Genau.
Nein. Das ist ein Kreuz, Schatz.
Jetzt guckst du nach einem Torx.
Guck mal. Da müsste irgendwo ein Torx sein.
Guck mal. Hier sind sie drin die Torx.
Jetzt guckst du, was passt.
Genau.
Und dann, Samira, guck mal ganz kurz zu.
Dann musst du es nur zurückziehen.
Jetzt ziehst du es raus.
Zieh es raus.
So. Jetzt kannst du wieder ein neues reinmachen.
Jetzt guckst du, dass eins passt,
und machst das mal zusammen.
Und genau so brauchst du ein zweites Teil.
Und das machst du jetzt auch so.
Das machst du kurz alles alleine, okay?
Ja. Ich habe es gefunden.
Hast du es gefunden?
Okay.
Dann konzentriere dich und mach das jetzt einmal.
Und das andere Mal machst du es komplett alleine, okay?
Hm.
Genau.
Du schaffst das.
Ich lasse es dich alleine aufbauen, Schatz.
Richtig cool!
Genau. Erst fixieren und dann anziehen.
Ganz cool!
Langsam, aber schön machen, okay?
Und immer alles sauber so wie Mama.
Du schaffst das! Komm.
Klasse, Schatz!
Du bist wie deine Mutter. Echt!
Du bist echt ein schlaues Kind!
Cool!
Und weißt du, was wir jetzt nachher machen?
Da hole ich nachher noch Farbe
und dann können wir das nachher noch anstreichen.
Okay?
So. Jetzt hast du es geschafft.
Habe ich ganz alleine gebaut.
Klasse, Schatz!
Cool, oder? Das ging auch richtig schnell.
So. Jetzt gehen wir eigentlich gleich raus mit den Kids.
Weil ich verbringe immer
zwei Stunden mit den Kids am Tag.
Und wir bauen im Haus zusammen,
wir machen Dinge,
wir machen den Garten zusammen sauber.
Das gehört auch dazu.
Aber wir haben jetzt schon lange
Oma nicht mehr gesehen, gell?
Hm.
Ja. Und wir können Oma gerade nicht sehen.
Und deswegen
tun wir jetzt einmal Oma und Opa mal kurz anrufen.
Weil die sind sicherlich daheim, oder?
Hallo!
Hallo! Hallo!
Hallo, Oma!
Dede.
Var dede, Ela!
Hallo!
Guck.
Ela, guck mal!
[Musik]
Ela, kommst du?
So. Und während ich mich dann um die Kinder kümmere,
kannst du dich um dich kümmern.
Okay?
Was soll das jetzt heißen?
Ich wollte nur sagen: Viel Spaß!
Habe ich jetzt Ichzeit?
Ja, du hast jetzt Ichzeit.
Und ich habe jetzt Wichtzeit.
Ja.
Gott sei Dank!
Viel Spaß!
Wenn ich in, wenn ich in...
Wenn ich in zehn Minuten,
wenn ich in einer halben Stunde nicht wieder da bin,
dann ruf die Polizei, okay?
Ja.
[Musik]
So mindestens zwei, drei Stunden am Tag
versuche ich, sie zum Arbeiten zu bringen.
Weil ihr wohnt ja auch kostenlos bei uns.
Habe ich recht?
Ja.
Also müsst ihr auch was dafür tun.
Wichtig ist natürlich, die Kinder
zur Selbstständigkeit zu bringen
und sie zu ermuntern, Dinge selber zu machen.
Und vor allem, ich bin Handwerker
und ich will halt natürlich auch,
dass sie das Handwerk wertschätzen
und Dinge selber machen.
Und die macht das auch richtig cool, die Samira.
Ich habe es jetzt einmal gesagt
und die macht das komplett alleine.
Und dann hast du deine eigene Picknickbank
mit der Ela zusammen, oder?
Ja.
Papa!
Und gestern hat sie es wirklich komplett alleine gemacht.
Und die Ela, die läuft hier halt rum.
Ist das dein Werkzeug, Ela?
Ja.
Sollen wir das später auch noch anmalen?
Nein! Das hat schon Farben.
Okay.
Was ist das?
Grün.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Blau.
Ja.
Rot.
Gelb.
Ja.
Also
die Ela weiß alle Farben schon.
Und, wie gesagt, die Ela ist...
Die Samira ist handwerklich wirklich extrem begabt
wie ihre Mama.
Und die Ela ist halt...
Schlau!
Ja. Die ist halt schlau.
Genau. Und das haben wir.
Erst haben wir diese Bank hier zusammen bei uns
im Gang gemacht,
weil es da nicht gewindet hat.
Und das sind Farben auf Wasserbasis.
Also das sind Acrylfarben auf Wasserbasis
und mit dem streichen...
Du machst das selber, okay?
Hm.
Du machst das komplett alleine.
Ela.
Kann ich mitmachen?
Nee. Pass auf. Das macht jetzt die Samira.
Und wir gehen lieber in den Garten
und tun ein bisschen arbeiten, okay?
Und ich mag aber da unten anstreichen.
Okay. Du darfst die untere Seite machen,
wenn die Samira fertig ist, okay?
Und auch hier das Untere.
Ja.
Das alles.
Das darfst alles du machen.
Aber jetzt darf erst mal die Samira, okay?
Und solange gehen wir in den Garten
und tun im Hochbeet was rauspflücken, okay?
Und ihr müsst jetzt alle mir helfen arbeiten,
weil du zahlst auch keine Miete. Oder?
Hast du schon mal Miete bezahlt?
Ja, ich habe schon.
Hast du schon mal bezahlt?
Nicht.
Du hast noch nie bezahlt, gell?
Du musst mir helfen jetzt dafür.
Dann kannst du umsonst bei uns wohnen.
Okay?
Ist es abgemacht?
Hand drauf.
Ja.
Ela!
Ela, bleib hier!
Bleib hier!
[Musik]
Ich erwische dich!
Nein!
[Musik]
Natur ist natürlich extrem wichtig!
Normalerweise ist Opa natürlich jetzt auch da
und hilft uns hier draußen.
Nicht jeder hat einen Garten. Ganz, ganz klar.
Aber wir haben zum Beispiel
auch einen Wald hier in der Nähe.
Wir machen zum Beispiel jetzt
mindestens zweimal in der Woche einen Waldspaziergang.
Und wichtig ist, deinen Kindern auch zu zeigen:
Guck mal.
Das ist eine Birke.
Das ist eine Eiche.
Das ist ein Nadelbaum.
Das den Kindern zu zeigen.
Auch das Erden zu zeigen.
Auch zu arbeiten.
Arbeiten ist für mich etwas extrem Wichtiges.
Ich bin jeden Tag gern draußen.
Ich arbeite viel.
Ich bin ein Handwerker, wie gesagt.
Und die Kinder sollen das auch lernen.
Die schätzen dann viele, viele Dinge mehr wert.
Wer weiß denn heutzutage, wie ein Baum entsteht,
wie ein Baum wächst, was dazu alles nötig ist?
Oder was ein Nadelbaum ist,
die ganzen Holzarten.
Und die Kinder wachsen hier auf.
Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Und auch gerade in dieser Zeit
ist es wichtig, oft mit den Kids rauszugehen,
sie natürlich warm anzuziehen.
Es ist noch ein bisschen frisch, ein bisschen kalt.
Aber das ist dann...
Drinnen kümmert sich die Sally um allem Drum und Dran.
Dann dürfen sie auch ihre Filmchen schauen
und ihr Zeug machen,
ihre Videos anschauen und was lernen mit der Sally.
Aber draußen geht es um die, in die wahre Welt,
sage ich mal so.
Und da bin ich dafür da.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
ob ich euch schon mal erzählt habe, dass ich
mehrere Handwerksberufe gelernt habe.
Habe ich euch schon mal erzählt,
dass ich eigentlich Offsetdrucker bin oder Drucktechnologe?
Habe ich noch nicht wahrscheinlich.
Das war ein Insider. Vielleicht hat es jemand verstanden.
Guck mal. Ela, hilfst du mir?
Ich sammle gerade meine Coins.
Was ist das?
Deine Coins?
Ja.
Okay.
Für die, wo nicht wissen, was Coins sind:
Das ist...
In der virtuellen Welt ist das Geld.
Sie sammelt ihre Coins momentan.
O Gott!
Woher weiß die – die ist erst vier –
überhaupt, was Coins sind?!
Ja.
Noch mal.
Schön frische Erde!
Was ist das?
Lass mal sehen.
Wow!
Das sind drei Coins! Die will ich alle haben!
Gib mir die Coins!
Alles meins!
Guck mal, Josh! Ich habe drei Coins!
Die gehören mir!
Die habe ich gesammelt.
He, meine!
Okay, wir können teilen.
Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck, okay?
Schnick,
Schnack,
Schnuck!
Gleich.
Noch mal.
Schnick,
Schnack,
Schnuck.
Ah, ich habe gewonnen!
Einer gehört mir.
Nein.
Noch mal eins.
Noch mal.
Jetzt sind es halt nur noch zwei, okay?
Schnick,
Schnack,
Schnuck.
Wieder gewonnen!
Papier frisst Dings.
Nein!
Noch mal, gehört auch mir.
Ja, ist halt so. Hast halt verloren.
Noch mal.
Schnick,
Schnack,
Schnuck.
Ah, ich habe gewonnen!
Gib den auch noch her.
Gib den her!
Nein!
Nein, du musst fair sein!
Dann dürfen wir noch mal spielen.
Ich habe jetzt gewonnen. Ich habe den letzten noch.
Nein!
Warte doch!
Jetzt sei doch mal fair!
Du darfst ihn...
Dann spielen wir noch mal.
Dann spielen wir um alle, okay?
Dann gibt den her. Komm.
So.
Pech gehabt! So.
He!
Mein Gott! Das gibt es doch nicht.
Ich will nur...
Da hast du deine Coins!
Komm.
Du süße Maus.
Du brauchst nicht immer gleich weinen!
Komm.
[Musik]
Also ihr seht, ich habe jetzt auch gerade keine Ichzeit.
Die Ichzeit nutze ich jetzt tatsächlich noch zum Arbeiten.
Die Ichzeit habe ich nämlich ganz gerne,
wenn die Kinder schon im Bett sind,
oder morgens ganz früh, wenn sie noch schlafen.
Da habe ich nämlich einfach meine Ruhe
und kann meinen Abend genießen,
was lesen oder eine Serie schauen
oder einfach nur dasitzen und eure Kommentare durchlesen.
Und jetzt,
was ich momentan mache, ist,
ich nehme gerade Videos ab.
Das heißt, ich schaue mir die Videos an,
die geschnitten wurden,
gucke, ob noch Änderungen da sind,
mache noch meine Rezepte fertig,
schreibe noch alles runter
und plane auch schon meinen nächsten Arbeitstag.
Und die Kinder werden ja jetzt gerade schon
oder immer noch von Murat beschäftigt.
Sie streichen ja draußen gerade den Tisch.
Ela macht wahrscheinlich was anderes
so, wie ich sie kenne.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass Ela mit den Tisch streicht.
Und wichtig ist, dass ihr euch als Eltern
momentan nicht den Druck macht und sagt,
ich muss mein Kind
auf Biegen und Brechen den ganzen Tag beschäftigen.
Denn wir haben momentan keine Ferien
und das war jetzt alles auch so ein bisschen
nicht vorhersehbar, was passiert.
Keiner wusste, dass wir jetzt
die nächste Zeit zu Hause verbringen.
Die Schwierigkeit ist eben auch,
die Kinder können jetzt gerade keine Freunde treffen.
Ela hat keinen Spielpartner.
Das heißt, die zwei sind wirklich immer nur zu zweit
beziehungsweise zu viert mit uns
oder in seltenen Fällen eben auch bei uns im Team.
Oma und Opa sind nicht da.
Also es ist schon eine richtig große Herausforderung.
Und man sollte aber auch wirklich
den Tag der Kinder nicht verplanen.
Also die dürfen ruhig auch mal Langeweile haben.
Kinder müssen sich auch mal ganz alleine beschäftigen.
Aus Langeweile entstehen meist die besten Ideen.
Okay, auch der größte Quatsch meist bei Ela.
Die stellt dann irgendwie immer was an.
Natürlich müssen sie beobachtet werden
und dürfen nicht allein gelassen werden.
Aber sie brauchen einfach ihren Freiraum,
um sich zu entwickeln,
um ihre Hobbys zu entdecken.
Die Samira geht zum Beispiel gerade total auf
in ihrer Rolle als Köchin und Bäckerin,
also wenn ich ihr die Verantwortung übergebe:
"Hey Samira, mach doch mal das Frühstück für alle."
Oder sie kommt sogar schon von ganz alleine auf die Idee,
steht morgens früher auf
oder möchte das Abendessen für uns alle machen.
Dann lasse ich sie auch.
Und jetzt könnt ihr wirklich gerade diese Zeit nutzen
und sagen,
wenn ihr im Alltag normalerweise nicht die Zeit habt
oder auch nicht die Geduld,
eure Kinder alleine in der Küche werkeln zu lassen,
dann probiert es doch einfach jetzt aus.
Samira stellt sich dann hin, schaut sich Videos an
oder geht einfach in meine App,
sucht sich ein Rezept aus und macht es einfach.
Klar, muss ich am Ende auch noch die Küche putzen
oder nachputzen, ein bisschen helfen beim Aufräumen.
Aber so kann sie zum einen lernen,
Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Sie wird selbstständiger.
Ihr Hobby entwickelt sich gerade,
also das Hobby zum Kochen und Backen.
Sie hat wirklich eine richtig tolle Leidenschaft dafür entwickelt.
Und es macht ihr einfach unheimlich viel Spaß.
Sie ist beschäftigt und sie tut was für die Familie.
Und das ist gerade echt was richtig Schönes.
[Musik]
Darf ich?
Hm.
Darf ich ihn aufrollen?
Das sieht voll schön aus.
Mmh, mit Dattelsirup.
Mama! Was steht da?
Da steht
Mermaid,
also Meerjungfrau.
Wow.
Ich bin so stolz auf dich, mein Schatz!
Mmh!
Ich habe noch nie so einen leckeren Pfannkuchen gegessen.
Ich bin so stolz auf dich!
Tschakka!
Backst du die jetzt noch aus?
Ja.
Dann esse ich solange den einen, okay?
Hm.
Machst du noch mal den Herd an?
Der ist an.
Oh.
Du hast den schon perfekt angemacht.
[Musik]
Das war jetzt heute so ein kleiner Einblick in unseren Alltag.
Der Alltag, der momentan ein bisschen anders ist als sonst.
Klar, wir haben jetzt jeden Tag
so ein bisschen die gleichen Strukturen.
Also morgens das Lernen, dann die Spielzeit
und dann eben auch für jeden die Zeit ganz alleine.
Und bei allem, was jetzt momentan passiert,
lasst bitte eure Kinder einfach nicht spüren,
falls ihr Ängste habt oder Sorgen habt,
wie es morgen weitergeht.
Viele werden jetzt vielleicht auch gerade
in Kurzarbeit gehen.
Und man weiß einfach nicht,
wann die komplette Situation sich jetzt wieder entschärft.
Aber bei allem, was passiert,
gebt euren Kindern einfach die Sicherheit,
gebt ihnen die Geborgenheit,
die ihr ihnen sowieso immer schon gebt.
Also lasst sie einfach von all dem nichts spüren.
Aber seid trotzdem transparent.
Das heißt, klärt die Kinder auf:
Warum können sie gerade Oma und Opa nicht sehen
oder die Tante nicht sehen?
Und warum kommen gerade keine Spielfreunde nach Hause?
Das ist wirklich immer superwichtig,
dass man sie aufklärt,
aber eben auch mit den negativen Dingen der Welt
nicht zu sehr belastet.
Also alles immer schön kindlich erklären.
Für uns ist der Alltag jetzt erst mal vorbei.
Samira und Ela spielen jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen,
haben so ein bisschen Ichzeit für sich.
Das heißt, sie vertrödeln ihre Zeit
oder spielen was auf ihren Zimmern,
schauen sich eine Serie an oder lesen ein Buch.
Und dann ist für uns der Tag jetzt auch schon wieder vorbei.
Morgen geht es wieder von vorne los.
Das heißt, ich achte jetzt auch wirklich darauf,
dass die Kinder abends pünktlich ins Bett kommen,
damit ich einfach für morgen wieder fit bin,
dass ich früh genug meinen Feierabend habe
und die Zeit mit Murat noch verbringen kann
oder eben auch mal ganz alleine.
Und das ist genau das, was die Elefanten tun.
Eines Tages werden sie
eine riesige Elefantenparade machen
und sich alle verkleiden.
Alle, nur nicht Elmar. Der ist ja schon kunterbunt.
Gell?
Und jetzt werden alle Elefantenbabys müde, gell?
Und gehen jetzt schlafen.
Gute Nacht, Schatz.
Gute Nacht.
Bis morgen.
Und wenn Samira ihre Medienzeit hat,
dann darf sie die YouTube Kids App eben auch benutzen,
wählt dann ihr Profil aus.
Und weil sie eben schon fast zehn Jahre alt ist
und lesen und schreiben kann,
sind bei ihr oben die Reiter
wirklich auch schön ausgeschrieben.
Das heißt, sie kann einfach wählen
zwischen Empfohlen, Entdecken, Serien,
Spiele oder eben auch Musik.
[Musik]
Gute Nacht.
Noch ein paar Seiten und dann schlafen, okay?
Hm.
Gute Nacht.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Kinder im Bett.
Jetzt ist Pärchenzeit.
[Musik]
Murat.
Dann habe ich jetzt halt Ichzeit.
[Musik]
Gute Nacht.